à la coop 25 on peut voir des militants
vegan on peut tisser du coton et écouter
des chants traditionnels chine et aussi
voir des stars de 16 à 77 ans dans le
haut de la pyramide des âges
harrison ford la théorie qui dit qu'il
vaut mieux écouter le cri d'alarmé des
jeunes et leur meilleure représentante
s'est elle
souvenez vous il y a un an à la coop 24
rite attenberg faisait un discours dans
une petite salle presque vide
les choses ont changé depuis
après avoir vu entre autres le pape
donald trump et montréal cette fois la
grande salle de la coop et combes et
elle ne veut plus des phrases chocs
comme celle ci je ne ferai pas ça parce
que c'est tout ce qu'on retient
alors elle se concentre sur les faits
scientifiques mais son attention a été
un peu troublé aujourd'hui plus jeune
personnalité de l'année du magazine time
un honneur incroyable a réagi
personne n'est trop petit pour avoir un
impact et changé le monde a dit barack
obama
en attendant les délégations du monde
entier ont jusqu'à vendredi à madrid
pour s'entendre sur des mesures
concrètes pour le climat ici mathieu
prost radio canada montréal